what up guys it's your girl jess welcome
back to the just pearly things channel
um don't forget to subscribe like the
video and comment today we are going to
be watching kevin samuels as i go from
blue pill to red pill
and today is his most savage moment
you're average at best okay you've seen
little clips from this yes i haven't
seen it all the way through
my heart my heart i got palpitations
right now this is this is part of her
journey and you need to let us know in
the comments who she's going to watch
next
this is going up this is vital okay
kevin if you're watching this
oh goodness i'm sorry
okay
actually smasher pass kevin samuel oh
yes
[Laughter]
those were hers
hey can you hear me yeah are you a phd
ah no i'm a phd
how many dogs you got
uh one
really
i'm sorry what kind of dog is it
he's a cane torso
he's a what
a cane corsa
what is that in english
um it's a larger dog and their breed is
meant for garden and protect and they're
very protective of their home and their
families so what's your disagreement
um honestly i don't have a disagreement
i just came here because i honestly want
some advice from you
it says disagreement day
i know but this is my first time
catching on live normally i'm asleep
and um you have a job
i do i own a business okay so i do too
and i do have a question but i have a
business and if you wanted my advice
you could always book a session if you
can't catch us at the show live
i'm definitely i was trying to go online
um earlier
but all you have to do man see what kind
of business do you own
i own a pet grooming doggy daycare and
okay so
what you're basically trying to do is i
have a disagreement day and you
basically came in and said damn your
topic
i want to ask you what i want to ask you
and that's but you are more than welcome
to go on my website and purchase your
time to talk with me one-on-one because
what you're trying to do is rather rude
but i will go ahead and do it because
i'm going to use this as a teaching
lesson
how old are you
how old are you i'm 35. 35 years old
35 years old and you're a business owner
uh-huh uh-huh and what's your question
um so my issue is well i want to know at
what point when i'm
just meeting a guy do i tell him that
i'm a business owner because
my problem is that
when i try to date down and i the
conversation comes up to where i own a
business um the guy is either like hey
can i come join in on you on that
business or can i put some money and be
a business partner and
i'm not looking for that and i honestly
hold on hold on hold on hold on i need
to be clear on this subject
where are you where are you at
no come on
first of all
if she's unhappy with dating down
why is she dating down
like
you're putting yourself into that
position to date now like when i date
that like
it doesn't make sure where is she
finding these men that want to help with
their business i run a business i need a
lot of help exactly i've never dated a
guy that's
like let me
if that's not the type of guy that
you
want why are you putting yourself in
that position to
why
and i agree with what he said in the
beginning he she's running the business
and she would be upset
if someone came in and was like i need
help doing something that your business
doesn't require but i'm here and you
have to help me like i understand that
like that's very disrespectful for her
just to be like
i wanted to come in and get advice and
he's like but that's not what today is
so
this is going to be interesting
and you're saying when to tell somebody
you own a business
because um i find when i date down
god for your interest and want to be
like a business partner and i'm i'm
learning that maybe i need a high value
mean because that's well first off um do
you know what a high value man is
i'm you've said it before i i
is it like a certain like
age bracket
tax bracket
okay so i i this
the to watch this conversation you have
to like put it in context to know what a
high value guy okay so there there's
five things that i butcher every single
time
and
one of them is income so he has to make
at least ten thousand dollars a month so
120k okay okay um another he has to have
earned that for five years or more he
has to have a network of men that are
and other men have to accept him into
the group
okay so it's like
a completely different caliber there's
there's like one or two more
requirements that i can't remember sorry
guys
that's that's so interesting because i
know
people who are
trying to become a high value man and
it's like you just think they're
operating through life but now they're
like strategically placing themselves in
areas to where they can be considered a
high volume in this yeah because the
network's part of it so you have to yeah
yeah wow that's very interesting most of
the guys like he doesn't really count
people under 30 and he doesn't really
count entertainers either like somebody
um they're like i think he would
probably consider jay-z a high-value man
because he he does other things other
than music it's not just he probably
would put kanye in that too
but
maybe
not kanye only because of the way he
carries himself in high value not like
carry them it's like business etiquette
but jay-z kind of carries himself this
way yeah you know what i'm saying that's
why
i'm not sure if he'd put me
but
i don't know but you see like it's
different than like poo scheisse like he
would not be considered a high value
yeah
yeah yeah unfortunately
ma'am i really understand uh
what kind of man are you talking about
because owning a business is no
different than having a job in my
opinion
i'm not getting what you're saying when
should you i'm not understanding why
this is an issue
if you're if you're
exactly why why is telling someone that
you that you own a business why is that
why is that the issue at hand like you
just say oh what do what do you do for
where oh i own a business it just comes
up in conversation i don't understand
yeah i i if you don't want to tell them
you run a business just say oh i work at
so and so or work for because you do you
don't have to tell them that you uh
run own a business i go
i need to find these guys that are
trying to help out yeah
i'm like help me start a business
run my business for me please okay
what kind of men are you what kind of
men are you dating
um i try to give i
try to give guys that
not just
a team you try to do what
i try to give guys that's not on my
level a chance
why what do you mean on your level what
does that mean that's making six figures
or more
but i don't under okay
you try to give guys who are not on your
level a chance
why
because i want i honestly want a six
figure guy uh is what i'm realizing okay
so let me just go ahead and net it out
for you
you ready
uh-huh
the guys you want aren't asking you out
well i'm i haven't been putting myself
out there honestly
but you put yourself out there enough
for the guys you don't want or believe
you to ask you out those like guys i met
online
right so
again
the men you want are not asking you out
see you ladies do this
you go and
deal with men who you feel are beneath
you and then you ask how
to fix them i'm not beneath you i don't
know how to fix a guy that doesn't
that's down there that's not my concern
the better question is why can't you get
a guy on your level
that's the real word
well the
why why do you think that is that
women
tend to do that cause we were talking
about that yesterday how women will go
for
typically the bum
except and
except for
to go for the bum and not go for someone
that
is more on their level
okay there's three reasons okay i've
laid out one bombs have a lot of free
time
so we usually got a game
as true um two okay i think there's some
girls that like dominating a
relationship and they like feeling
competent and so they like being with
someone less than them so they can like
shine
and i think third
um
i i think
looks like they can't because men and
women are valued for different things so
guys don't care how much money you make
gosh so that's like not that's like a
shoe collection to us like if a guy has
a shoe collection it's cool yeah
you're not going to be like
you got a lot of shoes
yeah because like they're we're valued
more on like how fit we are feminine and
friendly um and you know
attractive and she's just not like what
would you rate her one to ten oh don't
do that to me pearl
um
if you strip all the everything off
i'll just say
via solid
maybe right in the middle four or five
that's what i would give her
um so
yeah so that's
yeah just
well first of all i would tell you
what i said in here automatically is a
problem
why you would come onto a show that you
know was a disagreement day
it's selfish
it's like well yes ma'am it's sell it's
like i want what i want
i don't i don't say things for no reason
that's why i asked you questions you're
35 years old a business owner that means
you understand what business is you know
this is a business and i have a and i
have a show title and you said damn your
show title i want to talk to you
but you could have went to my business
and booked time to talk to me but you
wanted what you wanted how you want it
i'm sorry
no it's but and i'm using this as lesson
that's the problem with too many of you
black women you don't do [ __ ] the right
way with black men
that was improper
that
i've had a conversation like that before
about like just black women and black
men and
why
like we can
coexide in some areas but when it comes
to
like the i guess relationship side of
things
it's kind of like there's a disconnect
not with everybody but with
i would say a big chunk of it
it's a disconnect and
i i still don't understand why but i
know that
as a
i've heard black men say
that when it comes to
being with a black woman
it's
as if they have to be on all the time
and have to still prove themselves to
them and
they don't want to have to do that and
so they
they typically go for um
women that they don't have to
like prove themselves to and that
obviously is not true for everybody but
it's
one one thing that i have experienced
and
to believe like there's a standard that
black women have that subconsciously we
don't know about that we hold our black
men too and when they don't
meet those standards
it's like oh you're no good you're
just all like all these other dudes out
here
and it's hard for them to be held to a
standard that's not them and not to be
given a chance to be themselves they
feel like they have to be this
image all the time at work of out in the
streets
when they're with their friends family
whatever it's like when they come home
to their significant other they want to
be able to
relax and everything and so
why so it's interesting so i was going
to ask you if you felt like that was
true
yeah unfortunately yes obviously not
not the vast majority but it's true no
matter how big or small it is and
it sucks to hear
and as a black woman i think about that
and i'm like okay
when i am in conversations or in
relationships with
a black man or whoever how am i
how am i helping them when we're in the
same space together am i making them
feel inferior to me am i making them
feel
like they have to be on all the time or
is it a place where they can come and
relax and be
in solitude when they're around me so
why do you think that is
because i'm not i'm not black so i can't
wait
like so i can't speak to whether like
that goes on or not because it's not
i
i don't i don't know why it is i feel
like it shouldn't be that way i feel
like
we of all people
should understand
just
basically what it is to be black and
what we
like experience throughout the world
daily and we should be able to
not have to
put that on black men when we are in a
relationship with them or just in a
space with them but i think it comes
from
just
society and we subconsciously do it and
we don't know
we are doing it
and
until someone says something and you're
open to listen and understand it and
evaluate yourself like okay do i do i do
these traits subconsciously because it's
what my mom told me my grandma told me
like this is how it should be and
if you're not open to really think about
it you're going to keep doing it you're
going to be like no you're wrong i am
who i am i'm going to do how i do it if
you can't if you can't meet me where i'm
at then you're inferior to me and i
don't want you and it's like how are we
supposed to build up somebody if we're
not able to grow ourselves and then we
wonder why
they
leave and go
get
anybody else in a different race and
it's like we always say like oh he of
course he went there of course he went
there was like
think about why
it's not just because
oh they're white they're mexican they're
chinese or whatever it is there's
something that
as black women were doing to push them
away or there maybe have been something
that happened
to them by a black woman that pushed
them away and it's just like you have to
consciously evaluate yourself and ask
yourself
why
i would
yeah yeah
and when i even when i told you the
right way you still were like uh well
whatever
so i'mma use this
when was the last time you had a
relationship
um like the end of last year around
december how long did it last
a year
a year uh and was that man uh
did you go to college
did i go to college
yes
no sir
okay and how long have you owned your
own business
nine years
and how and how long have you been
making six figures or more
on the last three
okay why do you need a man making six
figures
um because i'm finding out that the guys
that i think that's not is not working
out
but why if you're making six figures why
do you need a man to make six figures do
you want him to support you in your
lifestyle when you can clearly support
yourself
if
why
i'm like this is for just women like why
is it essential
if you're making money and have money
yourself why is it essential that a man
needs
to
make that
exact money like you're like you have
said
a big bracket and you're taking this uh
um
the scale of men and you're minimizing
it to a handful that you they need to
make six figure i don't know what the
stats are on that but that is a handful
of men and you you want a speci a
particular man and when you have these
qualifications
you're making the pool smaller and
smaller not enough to ask for that are
you like
yeah like i don't know i just i don't
think she's hot enough to be making
these requirements
it comes a certain standard you gotta
you have to meet yourself to be able to
ask for that type of man so what does it
have to do with money
because i feel like
um
i need a god that i can respect and
admire and i'm a [ __ ] invention and i
want a guy
that has that drive too and when he
doesn't i find myself you know
encouraging like hey babe you can do
this and you can do that
and then so
he he may say it
a man that doesn't make six figures can
meet those qualifications
yeah
i
i know a lot of driven guys that make
70k a year that's great
60 like this is still above average
exactly like the qualifications
that she just listed off
a man does not have to make six figures
to
meet those qualifications why do you
only respect him if he makes that much
money like when my mom met my dad my
dad's a really hard worker he wasn't he
was broke
wow you started from the bottom now yeah
yeah yeah i mean but
like that's the thing like girls don't
look for qualities they look they look
for the guy who's already made it yeah
and that's the thing my my dad has
always been a hard worker he's always
been a workaholic yeah i feel like a lot
of
females are not willing to
be a ride or die we ride or die chick
and
it's like if you if you see him if you
see his ambition his drive and he's at
the bottom are you going to stick it out
and be with him when he goes through the
struggle and goes through the nose and
ups and downs to where in the end he is
making six figures or more like are you
willing to be there or do you just want
the
trophy at the end or even if he doesn't
so he stays 60 70. like police officers
firemen though yeah i'm a big uniform
type of guy if you wear a uniform
pearl
i'd be lonely
i'm just kidding
but not really
she's talking about she's not
just keep going in north carolina
what percentage of the population what
percentage of men in this country make
six figures or more
i think it's like five percent
i'm not
closer to ten
so
ten percent all right so
the question is what do those men who
make that kind of money who all women
tend to want
what do they want
i
feel like they want arm candy somebody
who can um
have more to bring to the table than
just looks but um
also bring
balance to their life i feel like i can
help them out on um okay slow down i'm
not understanding you said they won't
arm candy then you contradicted yourself
you want but they want somebody more
than just looks
yeah arm candy but something about you
know brain with it and
you know more in depth do you own do you
know any men who make six figures or
more
my dad and my uncle
do you know
excuse me do you know any men that you
are related to that make six figures or
more
unrelated to
yeah you are not related to
not on a personal level
so you don't know him
you don't know what they want
but you want him man
i'm going to suggest that you really
don't know
what you want
and saying six figures is just
something that you get
take
it's like
they
they see it they see the lifestyle and
they see
what
oh my gosh like that lifestyle like i
want a man that
can get me that lifestyle i was like why
don't you just create that lifestyle for
yourself if you
see it
like i said earlier why does a man have
to do it for you
and
one
it's very unprofessional her dogs are
barking in the background like
why are you gonna come that ghetto this
is a dog's barking in the background
i question if she makes six figures in
this video
i i don't i don't know i'm like okay
you're but it's funny you say this
because this is out of the horse's mouth
okay
the women want the lifestyle they don't
want the guy because you're not even red
pill and you're saying this
and red pill people say this all the
time
it's is i've just seen it and
i have
friends that
want guys like that
but it's
it's not even
for
for them to like feel like i want
someone who's like compassionate they
sat in the third but it's more so a
lifestyle that they want and then they
want the guy to be
to help them emotionally it's like if
that's something that you really want
why don't you look for that first and
then you yourself have the funds to
create your lifestyle instead of
depending on someone that
ultimately
may not stay with you for the rest of
your life
unfortunately and then you're depending
on this person and they leave and it's
like what what do you have what do you
have because you didn't do anything
yourself to create the life that you
wanted and then find somebody that can
come along and also complement your life
and you both mesh well together
well and they don't even talk about
i'm telling you my dad is one of those
guys that's in that income bracket and
they act like they're just gonna marry
these guys and do nothing that's not how
it works they have a hard work ethic
they're gonna put you to work yeah
you're gonna be working in the house
you're gonna be working for their
business or you you're gonna i promise
you
if you if you find a rich guy that just
wants you to do nothing
you're you must be really hot that's all
i got yeah exactly and
you
like she should know like okay instead
of just money that's all she said was
like oh i want a six figure type of guy
if you if you know what you want you're
going to put yourself into a position to
get that for her to say like oh i'm not
really putting myself out there oh i
just know my dad and my uncle is like
well you don't you're not
getting on the dating apps that have
those type of people like there's a
dating app called the league and you
have to
sign up for it and get
asked to come in and in those areas they
have
men that make substantial amount of
money but if you're not if you don't
know more than money what you want how
are how are you going to
have those men come to you how are you
going to know if a man comes up to you
he could look
he could wear
just a casual clothes and be making
money but you wouldn't know that because
all you see is all you think is money
and you think he's gonna be wearing a
suit he's gonna be looking like this
this is the image that i have in my head
and if that man does not come up to me i
don't want it no that's how my dad is he
drove like the speed-up van for like 15
years
now now they have nice cars and whatever
but they didn't get that till their 50s
when we were growing up
you would not have known
so we did have a nice house like
otherwise until you went to her house
y'all have money
but like we don't wear designer we don't
dress like super crazy it's like a lot
of those guys are frugal because that's
what kate that's what it takes to keep
generational wealth mm-hmm
that's all i want once i do have my
money i i'm gonna be frugal and whenever
if i do have kids they they're not gonna
love me a bargain
i love i love save i'm not about to be
like oh i have money now high-priced
things no we getting things on sale on
the clearance rack
still nice
taking from out there but i'm not
hearing this rooted to anything
what do you want ultimately do you want
to be married children what
yes i want to be married
do you want any children
yes
how many
um
i have a son you know so how's your son
he's 13
where's the father
he's not enough in his life
i said where's the father
well he's
not like in it like i would like them to
be
all right so um go ahead and take this
down man
men who make the kind of money you're
talking about have options
and typically i don't want to deal with
women who are have 13 year old sons who
are used to dating men who
this doesn't sound appealing
to the kind of man you're talking about
do you understand what i'm saying
yeah but um i was thinking once i start
booking session with you
that um i can't change men
i know but i can approve myself and i
feel like i have a lot to offer to those
type of me okay but it doesn't take away
the fact that
you have a child like you can
improve and first of all she said that's
why i won the book sessions why did you
do that in the first place ma'am
why are you here right now why did you
do that in the first place
and there's just there's just things
that
high value men look for and
i may be wrong but i don't think they
look for women who have children
you're absolutely correct
you're brothers don't you
do do they want to date single moms
no my my brother has a kid and he
doesn't want to date anybody that has
kids it's just
it's
it's just it sucks
that
she like i mean doesn't suck that she
has a child but she wants this type of
person but this type of person is not
looking for her because of
her her life and
it's like you have to you have to think
about reality and be realistic with
yourself and like okay is this
does this man look for this type of
people or is it am i being too
unrealistic let me
not settle but be realistic with your
life and it's not it'd be like if i went
to you and i i said i truly believe that
michael b jordan it's gonna it's gonna
hit on me
i'm like how explain to me how and so
people will say he's mean but he's just
being honest that's something it like
clicked in my head that i've
i'll say it at the end of the day
but see
you should have stopped right there
i just told you i cannot change men and
you said once i book a session with you
i'm not a miracle worker i'm telling you
what they want
and you're still saying yeah but i want
them they don't want you
but i have been working on myself this
year and um
okay ma'am but okay
35
13 year old son with a sketchy father
why would a man who's in the top 10 of
earners who women across the country
want want that
um because i have a lot to offer um i
feel like you want your son
to
if you had a son making that kind of
money would you want him to bring home a
woman who had a 13 year old son from a
sketchy father or would you prefer him
to get a woman who had no children who
was younger and easier to get on his
program
depending on his age
this is this
see what i mean see what i mean this
goes so deep for black women
they will even that should have been an
easy question
no i would not want my son to bring i
want the best for my son that should
have been the appropriate answer
that's why i sat up
that is [ __ ]
you should want the best for your son
of course
but this is
but
it's uh it's so
it's hard because it's the truth and
when you don't think about reality
reality sucks and you're like
man
if if i did have a son in that position
i wouldn't i wouldn't want she like i
bet you if she wasn't on camera and she
and they were just like in one of his
sessions she'd like no
i don't want my son to have to go
through
that because
she she knows firsthand what
what it's like and she wouldn't want him
to have to
experience that well and i've heard guys
that had single mom parents that told me
their mom told them not to date single
moms
because it shows a lack of
responsibility and being you're like it
shows you being irresponsible
like you're you're 27 i'm 25 we're not
pregnant bless those no yeah no kids
like like because we have so many forms
of birth control and like ways to not
get pregnant these days
so it's just
like
it's not fun but
you made your beds you got to lie in it
exactly
are you thinking
if he brought him in
yes i feel like i'm going to accept
but no you're not that's the problem you
all wait
what
did she
what
i feel like i'm the exception to the
rule ma'am i oh ma'am
does she explain how she feels she might
i haven't watched this clip in a minute
so we'll see
oh no
now
how do you how how do you feel like you
are the exception to the rule like you
just me i'm like
i think you're the exception to the rule
but but your life is proven to you that
you're not
my love life is not that good i agree
with you that's my point and ma'am and
that's my point
you ladies all feel like listen
you ladies all feel like you're the
exception to the rule
and then when someone like myself comes
along and gives you
a a dose of reality instead of just
accepting it it's like yeah but
yeah but i'm special
you don't know any men on this level
that are not your father that aren't
related to you that means you don't know
these men you don't know where to go get
them you don't know what they want
but you're still saying pick me they
don't want mid 30 year old baby mamas
are trying to be polite man but they
don't want those
i ask you a question
did you hear what i said
yes
why is that so okay go ahead
go ahead
um
my from my point of view i feel like i i
get what you're saying they they do have
better options but also those better
options are younger girls
those younger girls don't necessarily
are necessarily 20 year olds are not
necessarily attracted to 45 year olds
[ __ ]
i'm 51. i can't beat them off with a
stick
that's another one on you lies
no younger women are always younger
women are attracted to older men what
are you talking about
i know that first hand
i don't i don't know why they think like
younger women aren't attracted to older
men some of these some of these older
men i'm like
hello
you're 27. how old would you go oh
i'll say the oldest that i've gone and
it was
how old was that i was
20
25. okay uh
he was 42. 42. that's i would too
40s no no because okay i right around
24-25 i wasn't attracted to older guys i
i you couldn't tell me in a million
years that and then 25 ish 24 i would
say i started looking i'm like our dad's
hot
you don't have no kids
and
that was the problem i dated a 40 year
old
and he bamboozled me with children oh
yes
this guy guys guys this man
oh my gosh i've told this story on my
channel before but basically like
it's a story for a different day i was
bamboozled didn't know he had
goodness
i i don't know why people think that
like
young like i just said young people
don't go for older people just like
maybe not 18 year olds oh yeah yeah but
but 25 okay
let me speak
ma'am
i do okay
exactly
so can you see me
yes i can
okay
so do you feel like a woman like me
uh-huh what would you rank yourself on a
scale from one to ten you cannot use
seven
would i rate myself
just your face
uh my face is when i wake up five but
when i put myself together six
okay
and how tall are you
five five dress size
i'm sorry your dress size
okay so that makes you
if you give yourself a five that's
average
yes
so average looking women
tend not to get
high earning men
they tend to get average men
so um did you did you i mean stop right
there stop right there
stop right there breathe and digest
you're 35 years old and you can look
around and see the world
you don't tend to see
higher earning men
with average looking women
off rip
if you do see them they got them they
got their average looking woman when
they were both really young and he built
his way up but a man earning the kind of
money you're talking about does not go
for an average looking woman
i mean my body is not average so but
you can't ask you about your body and
it's
you can tell she's getting irritated
because she's moving looking on her
phone it's like man just listen listen
nobody say if you don't agree with it
okay you don't agree with it but you
don't have to be disrespectful on camera
and start looking at your phone you
you are
taking up his not taking up his time but
you are using his time and he's telling
you this it's it sucks to hear but if
you you rated yourself it's not like
something he took a poll and people
raised you you rated yourself you raised
yourself average
and if you want a high value man they're
not they're not looking for you they
look past you physically and literally
you're five five they're gonna look past
you completely now if you it's like she
said my body's not average they don't
care they're not what are they gonna do
that's called
if your face is a five and you have a
body on ten your butter face i'm i'm
sorry it's just it's just what it is
they're not they're not going to look at
you like oh wow your body looks good
they have to talk to your face and if
they're not if they're not attracted to
your face they're not gonna
i go on somewhere and you've got a kid
yes and when if you if she started
dating high volume men and she didn't
mention that she had a kid and she
started dating all these men and then it
came up oh i have a kid they're they're
gone
they're gone in an instant ghost casper
ma'am you please don't make me say it
say what
i really just wanted some advice i love
you i'm giving you i'm giving you advice
but you're not taking it the advice is
ma'am
ma'am
you're average looking at best
i'm taking it in but
okay but you're not accepting the fact
that
okay
average looking women
average looking woman who's older
average looking older woman with a 13
year old son
average looking woman with a 13 year old
son with a sketchy baby daddy
this gets worse every time i say
something and now you're asking for a
man who's in the top 10 of men
you don't qualify for one
and you're making i mean i don't i don't
want to have to go there
but when you put in the all these other
factors
why can't you just get a man that's
an average guy
sometimes i feel like um
in order to fully submit i have to feel
like he's in well then you're gonna then
you're gonna die alone how about that
all right let me just cut to the chase
man uh you can feel like what you want
to but women like you die alone
straight up
because you think you're better than the
men that you qualify for and the only
reason honestly ma'am that i can see a
woman like yourself really thinking you
deserve more is because you earn more
because you earn more money than most
people around you in north carolina
but if your ass worked at the post
office you would not think so highly of
your opportunities
and that's the reality we don't men
don't care about your money
not the kind of mean that you want we
don't care about your money
i say that's facts like there
and i i always thought like
high value men want a high value woman
they want someone that is just on their
level as them but as i get older
they don't care about your money they
have their money and they
i would say they expect you to have
yours as your own money as well
and
it's
like they care that you're maybe
financially yeah yeah and you're not in
like a ton of debt but what's your money
to someone that's got it no exactly
because nothing you're you're not about
to
take care of them and what what is so
bad
about
getting someone that's on
your level
that
compliment that is on your level in
everything not just financially but on
your level in
looks or like he was saying just
a good society standards average but has
all the qualities you want it doesn't
have when people i think that's what it
that's one thing is like when people
think like oh i'm this i'm that i should
get someone like that and anyone beneath
me is a bum essentially and doesn't do
anything with their license like that
you're canceling out
every other hard-working person that
isn't making six figure but they're
making the money that they want to make
and it do you think that it's society
like doesn't humble women ever because
if society basically says you could be
as fat as you want you're still
beautiful
you can be
you can um you could be a boss chick you
could be independent sleep with whoever
you want none of this will make you less
marriageable
and
like like i just feel like when we're
never told reality it's confusing
i i
yeah i've
i can see that firsthand that
like if if a guy goes on a platform and
says i don't date single moms he's he
what's the first thing people say
you hate single moms you're cancelled
it's like
why
why like in that case why would that be
a bad thing it's just his his preference
like yes it sucks and it's reality but
it's
it is what it is and
for her for her to say that i'm the
exception
that's like the table question like what
do you bring to the table and they're
like i am the table get
out of here with that mess like
then you essentially bring nothing to
the table because if you're the table
nothing's on you and you bring nothing
cool you got that's a real empty table
yeah yeah be hungry
exactly
you're at the table okay
then this man's just gonna
bring his own stuff
and how do you
okay
it ain't ours and we care about the fact
that you are older and you got kids
and your average
and your reality of your life has showed
you that
you don't have the kind of meaning that
you want
knocking on your door trying to find you
what we've done in this country this
world is we've told women like yourself
that
you can have it all
and you got a prince charming who's six
foot a hundred
six feet tall
six-figure income jawline all this other
kind of stuff and i'm sorry man
no
most people get average people
especially average people
and you're an average person
i mean let's be real you're not running
microsoft you got you had a pet grooming
business
you've been making six figures for the
last three years
okay
but if i'm looking at you but if i
looked at you and i took all that off of
you all the eyelashes and all the hair
what do you look like under there
i mean i look the same i'm just no you
don't cause if you did you wouldn't have
all that on
i'm sorry
no you don't
you don't look the same because if you
did you wouldn't have all that on
so
what is your advice
for us we did that all right i'll tell
you my advice man because you're not
listening to me this is why i always
recommend you need native speak therapy
everyone people think most of us in
black community need therapy but you're
not you're not dealing with reality
i asked you about your child's father
and you couldn't answer me
but it doesn't sound like you're too
proud of him
how's your what kind of student is your
child
he's a a student
does he have any behavioral problems
no he actually got a youtube channel and
he's trying to i don't need that i don't
need no no no
but where is it but his daddy is still
if his daddy is alive
does he have a relationship with his
father
then what's your issue with him
um he's not um business-minded like my
father and my uncle and then why'd you
choose to make a baby with him before
you got married
young and dumb i was 16. exactly and
that cost
see
that yummy dumb [ __ ] let me stop you
right here that young and dumb [ __ ] you
black women throw out as if it's
supposed to give
listen and listen well women young and
dumb is not a get out of jail free card
it doesn't go woof and change the fact
the fact that he asked her
if you take off everything like what you
look like she said the same it's like
nine times out of ten
no
it's very
rare that
if a woman is all done up everything
that when she takes everything off that
she's going to look the same as one
reason personally like as i was growing
up i was like you know what
i'm not i'm not gonna wear makeup
because i don't want it to come down to
a day where i meet somebody that i
potentially maybe want to marry and i
look different and then i'm at home just
relax
and chill and they're like who are you
and everything and some some men don't
care but essentially it's like it's a
big thing
no that's so funny you said that because
i had the same
experience like i i think sometimes my
problem is
i know you guys tell me in the comments
i come off a little too homeless
like
like maybe i should but but i i don't
like wearing a lot of makeup because i'm
not trying to deceive a guy with what i
look like i'd rather look how i look get
what i get
then
put all this [ __ ] on yeah and then i
have a guy that only likes me with it on
exactly i'm like you gonna see this
naked face you're gonna see it's all
imperfections and if you like it you
like it if you don't cool well and and i
think i've noticed like guys take me a
little bit more seriously when you don't
have like the fake lashes and all that
stuff like that i i feel like that kind
of puts you in the for fun category to
guys when you
have it like all done up
yeah not just when it's like super thick
makeup all the time fake out you know
the look where they don't look real like
guys don't want to make that a wife
exactly because
in my in my eyes you're you're dating
two different people it's like when
you're out and about
they look one way and then when you go
completely different and
personally
i don't i don't want that and
it's
she's
she's
disillusionable and for her
not to respect this man and his platform
his business and be on the phone and
she's laughing at whatever message that
is popping up on her phone it's like i
if if i was him i'd be like all right
ma'am bye have a great day and i just
would have ended the conversation like
you clearly
one don't want to listen and two don't
want my help because of the way you are
acting yeah it's disrespectful she's
looking down the whole time exactly it's
like if you don't like what you hear
are you going to only take the things in
life that you like hearing and never
anything that goes against what you what
you believe or what you deem as truth
like you can't
it's life you're going to hear things
that you don't believe or don't
understand
grow and understand it
you still have to carry that consequence
and men are not rushing up to be
stepfathers to 13 year olds
what would be better is if you honestly
sat down and ask yourself what value can
i bring to a man
and i know that what i can well
all right what can what value what what
is it
what is it
i can help him with his business i'm
very business minor on the um end of
health and organizer and
i plant um into planting my own garden
so
i can definitely plant i'm into um
improving my elegance with um
just self-improvement and
working on myself and ma'am at 35 years
old at 35 years old here's what you told
me
i can help him with his business do
respect ma'am
um and i mean no disrespect but 20 to 30
percent of people own businesses what
about the 70 to 80 of men who don't own
them
that means that doesn't matter
that means nothing to the average man
then the next thing you said
i can plant
man
that means nothing to most people
because we go to grocery stores
then you say
self-improvement you've had
i gave you a shot at saying what you
have to offer to me and you said nothing
that we value
well what do you got what yeah book a
session bigger session book a session
i'm not doing this nope nope nope nope
i'm done i'm done i've tried to go
around but this happens the older you
ladies get the more you get set in your
ways book a session cause i don't want
to do this in public man cause you seem
like a sweet woman but you don't but
you're not getting it you're being so
mean i'm not being don't tell me i'm
being mean
well
i'm about to be mean i get tired of you
broads telling me i'm being mean because
you cannot handle the damn truth you
called my show on the day the training
was supposed to be here and i honored
the call and sat here and tried to help
you and i'm telling you telling me i'm
being mean the [ __ ] out of my phone
she whips out her phone exactly exactly
oh
goodness
essentially what she said is i'm the
table if you like like if those are
things you like if you like planting and
self-improvement
go to those realms where men are go to
a community garden and see like what men
are there you may never know you may
find a farmer that is making six figures
and you guys can go plant and have your
farm together it's like farmers do bring
in a lot of exactly like where do you
think we get all our stuff from in the
grocery stores farmers and so you it's
oh my god okay
so do you think kevin samuels is a
little misrepresented after watching so
that's what i was gonna say when i first
saw this i was like
how dare he
but now that i've seen the whole clip
because i've only seen kevin
samuels in like little snippets and what
people bring out of the comment
in context i've never seen a full video
of kevin samuels
he's not that bad he's not that bad
smasher pass i still pass on him too old
50. is he really 50 yeah oh he didn't
look like it
i
will funny thing is
throughout the thing i was like
maybe a little bit more smash but still
so passed so past
what he was saying it was it was just
reality yeah and some people cannot
understand reality or take take it as as
it is and it it hurts but it's reality
no it that's so true because
she asked
you
you know i've called to his show really
yeah it was when i had a boyfriend he
like low-key
insinuated i dumped him i did
the last one yeah okay
good job
thanks kevin
um okay
okay guys um you want to do the outro
yeah well thank you guys for watching on
this reaction on um me going from blue
pill to red pill don't forget to
subscribe
like and comment down below
what other videos we should react to
okay guys we'll talk to you next time
bye